et les chéris euh c'est un véritable SOS
que notre patron d'un zoo refuse dans
une vidéo qui a été déjà vu plus de 13
millions de fois maintenant c'est 15
millions hein deux fois l'objectif est
simple sauver les 650 animaux qu'il
accueillent alors que le refuge est au
bord du gouffre et a besoin de 2
millions d'euros pour Patrick violas les
banques ne veulent pas dépenser d'argent
pour sauver des animaux pourtant ces
animaux Patrick les a sauvés alors
qu'ils étaient cobayes en laboratoire
travailler dans des cirques et forcément
c'est vrai que ça a été énormément
relayé on va voir la vidéo une petite
vidéo récap et il sera avec nous juste
après Patrick violas
en mars 2020 près de Chartres Patrick et
Francine décide d'ouvrir un zoo refuge
où il sauve et recueille plusieurs
animaux en détresse issus de divers
trafics
de la crise sanitaire le couple se
retrouve dans l'incapacité d'accueillir
du public pendant de longs mois
conséquences Patrick et Francine sont
aujourd'hui au bord du gouffre et se
sentent délaissé le regard à la tanière
tapas ou sa casse aujourd'hui
désormais endetté le couple qui craint
pour son zoo refuge a décidé de lancer
un appel aux dons
pour pouvoir continuer à le faire
fonctionner
le cri du cœur d'un patron de zoo ce
soir dans TPMP
Patrick violas merci d'être avec nous
patrons du refuge
patron du refuge la tanière vous avez
très bien réussi dans votre
vie précédente ce que vous faisiez quoi
on avait une chaîne de magasin de
téléphonie mobile dans les belles années
de la téléphonie mobile avec mon épouse
on a démarré tous les deux on a cédé
notre entreprise en 2009 on avait 1800
salariés de 70 magasins à travers la
France d'accord bon donc c'était une
très belle réussite et vous avez décidé
de mettre votre argent et votre temps au
service des animaux c'est ça exactement
on aurait pu partir sur un voilier ou
ailleurs mais on voulait partir d'un
projet non lucratif et on s'est occupé
d'animaux de sauver des animaux les
animaux qui sont chez nous sont pour les
deux tiers les animaux placés par les
autorités saisit sur du trafic d'animaux
le trafic d'animaux dans le troisième
trafic au monde bien détention illégales
dangereuse les animaux issus du monde du
spectacle aussi et des animaux des
primates sorties de laboratoire après
avoir travaillé sur les maladies
d'Alzheimer et Parkinson alors c'est ça
c'était un projet que vous aviez plus
longtemps
venir donc c'est un sou ou c'est un
refuge en fait c'est un refuge c'est un
zoo pas nécessité économique c'est ça
c'est un refuge les animaux qui sont là
et que le public peut voir sont là pour
faire le job pour pouvoir continuer à en
sauver d'autres donc vous sauver de
nombreux animaux que vous trouvez où en
fait comment vous sauver de nombreux
animaux que vous trouvez où en fait vous
récupérez où alors souvent la plupart
c'est des animaux qui sont saisis par
les autorités les polices les gendarmes
qui les saisissent sur du trafic
beaucoup de en ce moment la grande mode
c'est des petits fours les petits Serval
les petits caracals les petits singes la
détention illégale et dans des mauvaises
conditions on a été récupéré il y a pas
très longtemps dans une table qui
faisait 1 m sur un mètre qui servait
peut-être de salon pour voir l'apéro
trois petits singes enfermé là-dedans
depuis une dizaine d'années on voit des
choses c'est la grande mode en ce moment
c'est qu'en vrai
moi je me suis je me suis réveillé cette
nuit je me voyais qu'une panthère noire
avec une panthère
en fait je crois que c'est parce qu'en
fait je voulais peut-être venir faire
une panthère noire faire venir une
panthère noire à la maison et ça c'est
interdit ça je vous jure que c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai que en ce moment il
y a un gros truc au niveau des faux il y
a vraiment des des trafics incroyable
les gens prennent des Serval ou des
caracals avec des gros chats des vendent
à la fin comme étant des comme étant des
chats mais c'est très dangereux c'est
pas des c'est pas des jouets alors les
problèmes ont compensé dès le départ du
projet vous deviez ouvrir au public en
mars 2020 et ça a été le début du
confinement donc forcément c'était pas
le c'était pas le moment vous avez perdu
énormément d'argent 7 millions d'euros 7
millions d'euros c'est que mon
épouse-moi dans ce projet avant pas
investi ni les 30 millions d'euros qu'on
avait gagné dans notre vie précédente ça
fait gagner 30 millions d'euros de
livraison ils ont tout mis dans dans le
refuge pour les animaux on est content
c'est une somme énorme à 30 millions
d'euros
et là aujourd'hui vous en êtes où alors
on devait avoir au printemps 2020 il y a
eu le covid après on a pu ouvrir le 11
juin 2021 jusqu'au 20 juillet 2021 ça
fonctionnait très bien et beaucoup de
monde 21 juillet 2021 il y a eu le Pass
sanitaire alors qu'on est sur 20
hectares en plein air on a perdu 90 % de
nos visiteurs on traîne depuis à Boulay
on a et qu'on épouse remis tout ce qu'on
pouvait on a hypothéqué notre maison on
a fait tout ce qu'on pouvait aujourd'hui
on traîne encore un passif de 2 millions
et demi d'euros on a lancé un appel sur
le réseau sociaux samedi dernier qui par
chance depuis samedi à féminin près de
15 millions d'euros de vue 15 millions
pardon pas 15 millions d'euros j'espère
après voilà j'espère mais ça veut dire
que ça vous a coûté déjà 32 millions et
demi en tout puisque
pendant la crise on n'avait pas le droit
aux aides parce que toutes les aides
étaient basées sur le chiffre d'affaires
de 2019 on avait pas là on a eu un petit
peu d'aide de l'État et de la région
mais c'est un million sur les 7 millions
qu'on a perdu on les en remercie mais ça
ça a pas bouché le trou donc aujourd'hui
et depuis samedi on a heureusement
récupéré la moitié de la somme aucun
million
vous avez besoin de deux on a besoin de
deux et demi pour faire quoi pour pour
te dire combien de temps finir payer nos
fournisseurs dans les jours qui viennent
on est dans l'urgence on est dans
l'urgence et puis on va attaquer notre
saison là maintenant là il s'est les
vacances il fait beau il y a plein de
monde plein de monde chez nous on a
besoin de finir de payer nos
fournisseurs qui nous servit dans la
construction sont des gens qui
travaillent depuis très longtemps et qui
nous font confiance qui nous ont
accompagnés on a besoin de finir sur le
dessin pour pouvoir continuer à
accueillir des animaux on a des appels
pour les animaux tous les jours que ce
soit du monde du spectacle des saisies
ou de laboratoires
il y a des subventions de l'État pour
des eaux qui mettent en cage des animaux
pour le plaisir et là on a un monsieur
qui a donné sa vie qui a hypothéqué sa
maison qui a donné toutes ses économies
pour sauver des animaux et avoir une
réelle cause et là il se retrouve dans
cet état là et moi ça ça me révolte
totalement et c'est pour ça qu'on est
tous là pour le soutenir et on le
partage au maximum et en 2022 la tanière
a accueilli 140 000 visiteurs quand même
aujourd'hui quand une voiture est saisie
qui a déplacée en fourrière ou placée
chez la gare qui doit la garder il
facture du gardiennage de la voiture pas
nous
d'autant plus si c'est l'État qui
parfois vous sollicite nous amène les
animaux mais on le fait bien volontiers
dans le tiers des cas c'est l'état mais
on le fait bien planter c'est notre cœur
de métier c'est le job c'est ce qu'on
avait décidé de faire alors oui on
voudrait bien que de la même manière que
sur les pour les animaux de laboratoire
il y a une petite taxe sur les
médicaments que tout le monde entier
mais aujourd'hui ce qui nous réconfort
c'est que le grand public la vogue
populi qui est derrière nous a compris
que c'était le job de tout le monde
quand viennent chez nous visiter ils
achètent des billets ou quand ils vont
sur notre site nous faire des dons ils
savent pourquoi ils le font quoi ils
savent sur le parc aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui encore hier depuis cette
vidéo depuis toujours on voit des gens
venir avec les petits rouges pendant les
bras et
on va voir une petite vidéo de la
tanière qui mène de nombreux opérations
pour sauver les animaux et notamment les
animaux qui sont issus du trafic lors de
perquisition auxquelles ils
participaient regardez ces exemples de
quelques animaux sauvés après Gilles je
crois que vous voulez intervenir
là-dessus avec plaisir ça va vous êtes
quel est votre position là-dessus
moins favorable que beaucoup
donc voilà avec plaisir
je vais vous dire on a on a comme à
l'Assemblée on a notre France insoumise
pour vous parler de la dernière
opération de la tanière nous sommes
intervenus sur une grande saisie
d'ampleur national mené par l'OSB on
intervenu sur ces deux ouistitis on a
aussi récupéré un rack vous allez voir
donc il va se refaire une santé et aussi
à cacatoès qui est là également qui
était en détention illégale et surtout
et surtout on a récupéré ce Serval qui
grogne un peu qui parviennent au poivre
c'est un jeune il a 8 mois et on une
boîte énormément il a mal on va faire
maintenant les Radios échographies etc
ça va pas étonné qu'il ait une patte de
patte de cassée
on est avec Patrick violas un patron du
refuge la tanière qui s'occupe de
nombreux animaux qui est en détresse
totale qui a investit 30 millions
d'euros à 30 millions d'euros
dans cette affaire je comprends pas
parce que je là c'est le
l'ami financier qui parle je comprends
pas quand on a 30 millions d'euros on
lève on peut lever 200 millions
comment vous avez pas réussi à lever
l'argent pour la tanière que c'est pas
une cause qui intéresse non mais c'est
ça parce que c'est ce que je me dis je
me dis mais même les 30 millions d'euros
si on les place bien si voilà vous
auriez pu peut-être les les placer et
peut-être investir avec ce que vous
gagnez à 30 millions d'euros je vous le
dis vous les placez même à 2%, ça vous
fait un million et demi d'euros par an
vous avez fait
là mais non peut-être investir petit à
petit
je vous pose des questions que les gens
se posent non mais je vous dis
à mettre tout de suite 30 millions
d'euros il y a des bâtiments chez nous
qui coûte très cher le un bâtiment
important chez nous c'est le bâtiment de
quarantaine où tous les animaux qui vous
a suivi pardon il y a pas une banque qui
vous a suivi les banques nous ont fait
quelques prêts mais c'est parce que je
vous dis tout ce que je pense parce que
comme ça et moi je vous le crois
vraiment de bonne foi et je pense que
voilà et je pense qu'on va je pense que
moi un moment quand vous allez à la
banque quand vous avez 5 elle va vous
prêter 20 quand vous avez 30 à vous
prêter
si vous si vous avez des garanties en
face à un moment mais c'est vrai que tu
dis une banque c'est un refuge la banque
on aurait ouvert un zoo ah d'accord et
vous répétez oui ils sont devenus autres
Patrick qu'est-ce que je dis et je
trouve que et moi moi j'adore votre
façon de demander parce que je pense que
vous êtes tellement un passionné et
tellement un amoureux des animaux que
vous avez fait passer votre passion
avant avant l'économie avant peut-être
un montage financier qui vous aurait
permis peut-être de le faire autrement
voilà c'est qui je pense que c'est ça
voilà ça je vous dis c'est votre passion
qui a pris le pas sur peut-être un
montage financier qui aurait été plus
pérenne pour vous et vous auriez pu
voilà juste pour prendre un exemple pour
illustrer alors on a chez nous des lions
des ours éléphants etc un soir il y a
pas très longtemps il était 19h30 à
dimanche soir on était à la maison tous
les deux avec mon épouse le téléphone
sonne à la bourre qui nous appelle voilà
j'ai 250 bébés lapins qui sont nés comme
ça cette semaine mais les chercheurs
sont pris un peu de patients ils ont
tous une oreilles comme ça une oreille
comme ça si j'ai pas une solution demain
matin ils sont broyeur
il est 19h30 mais vous avez le temps
pour vous prononcer il nous faut la
réponse à 20h je dis non économiquement
je dis non je dors pas de la nuit je dis
oui je dors pas de la nuit non plus
c'est ça
mais voilà on a ramené on nous a appelé
l'autre jour on a ramené 200 ans par
avion d'Israël alors c'est l'ital
d'Israël qui a payé le transport 200
âmes qui partaient vers la Chine la peau
servant à faire des produits médicaments
voilà ils sont là d'ailleurs ça a été un
hôpital c'est une maison de retraite
c'était un refuge où les animaux qui
arrivent ici sont souvent mal en point
pour souvent vécu dans des cages enfermé
etc on leur offre à l'avenir voilà la
vidéo et on a chance d'avoir cette Voice
populiste public derrière nous qui est
là qui comprend notre action c'est aussi
des animaux après de la des primates
après avoir travaillé sur des maladies
d'Alzheimer kinson notre emblème c'est
la petite cannelle la petite cannelle
c'est une petite macaque grande comme ça
qui est rentré dans une cage de la boîte
2 ans qui est sorti à 21 ans qui a fait
trois cycles je sais pas si on peut dire
un gros mot ici-bas qui a fait quoi et
non pas là si cette cannelle on lui doit
pas une de retraite qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sur terre et il a tenir donc l'objectif
c'est de trouver ces animaux aussi de
faire de la pédagogie c'est pour ça
qu'on est ouvert au public expliquer aux
enfants qu'on va pas se faire prendre en
photo avec un lion sur une plage ou avec
un tigre dans une boîte de nuit le soir
que ces animaux qui se font prendre en
photo avec les gens sur les plages sur
des mots côté dégriffés côté castrer
bébé qui ont des tas de problèmes et les
animaux leur place et dans la nature on
espère qu'un jour c'est autre chose
c'est qu'un jour il y ait plus besoin de
la tanière et on mettra les mains déjà à
la place et là on gagnera de l'argent
j'ai refait un résumé de la vidéo je
vais jouer moi pour la tanière à
Chartres
chacun fera quelque chose Mathieu non
votre projet il est magnifique je
viendrai avec plaisir néanmoins quand je
suis perturbé par tout ce que vous
énoncez au niveau de l'argent vous dites
avoir injecté 30 millions vous avez des
dettes liées à des fournisseurs
5 millions pour la construction de
bâtiments c'est bien ça au départ vous
leur devez vous leur devez des millions
pour bah si vous leur donnez des
millions à des fournisseurs liés à la
construction de bâtiments donc moi ma
question elle est claire est-ce que vous
ne voulez pas faire payer par les dons
votre incapacité à gérer le projet et
est-ce que le projet
[Musique]
beaucoup plus nombreux que et puis que
aujourd'hui j'ai appelé tout à l'heure
j'ai vérifié il nous reste une loge et
qu'après vous devrez passer vous avoir
fait passer par la quarantaine pour vous
des bactéries on pourra vous mettre dans
une très jolie love que vous avez vu oui
mais moi aussi je veux sauver plein
d'animaux mais à un moment si on peut
pas non mais si on peut pas
financièrement est-ce que est-ce que
vous le voyez pas trop grand monsieur
c'est ça
le problème c'est le problème dans la
pub mais vous m'avez dit si j'ai 200000
visiteurs par jour par an pendant
il rachète beaucoup de choses par an
pardon on est flat je ne gagne pas
d'argent et vous dites aujourd'hui on
est à 2 ou 3000 on fait rien c'est déjà
les 200000
c'est dur de les faire donc comment vous
allez vivre dans les 200 000 c'est pas
dur de les faire on va les faire on va
les faire cette année et on va les
dépasser après on va faire 240 000 dans
un camping attention on vit de deux
choses à la tanière oh oui des entrées
du public et donc et de la gélaturité
publique d'accord on a deux sources de
revenus ah et ce que l'on doit à nos
fournisseurs aujourd'hui c'est pas des
millions par rapport au 30 millions
qu'on a mis c'est 2 millions et demi
d'euros et depuis samedi on a déjà
récupéré la moitié voilà d'accord donc
on va récupérer le reste et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas remboursé vos
fournisseurs dès le début en général
excusez-moi excusez-moi je vous pose une
question simple j'ai vu derrière Cyril
là des petites bicoques en bois sur la
la photo précédente de la tanière voilà
il y a des petites pas là mais là une
autre photo de la tanière il y a des
petites passer là non plus il y avait
des petites en bois c'est ça qui
vaut des millions d'euros moi je vous
pose des questions que les gens se
posent je veux expliquer ces petites
bigotes comme vous vous appelez sont des
loges pour des c'est des petites loges
volontairement petite pour des primates
qui sortent de laboratoire qui est à 20
ans ou 15 ans n'ont jamais vu un autre
primate de leur vie et qui on peut pas
de mettre demain dans une loge de 300
mètres carrés et qui nous servent à les
mettre deux par deux côte à côte pour
faire de la mise en contact et créer des
groupes et il y a des gens qui jouent
une nuit veillent dessus pour pas que ça
se bagarre quand on crée des groupes ça
c'est à cause de ça vous avez aussi des
bâtiments comme une clinique vétérinaire
qui est sûrement à la clinique la
vétérinaire la mieux équipée 100 km
autour un bâtiment de quarantaine ou
l'air échanger toutes les six minutes
qui a coûté à 1000 ans et demi d'euros
un bâtiment pour éléphant c'est
complètement pour un enfant sur plus de
parc qui a coûté un million et demi
d'euros vous voyez ça c'est ce que tu
fais tu es en train de faire douter des
gens qui pourraient être des questions
par exemple
je suis pas sûr
mais non juste euh dans ses règles
complet ok c'est quoi ton si cet appel
aux dons là fournit les résultats
escomptés est-ce que vous n'allez pas
refaire dans quelques mois un autre
appel au don parce que vous serez devant
déficit dans la ça va être bon après ça
va vous remettre le covid nous a coûté 7
millions d'euros on a réussi 5 à 4h30 il
nous reste deux et demi on les bouge et
c'est terminé alors continue à
accueillir les animaux et à fonctionner
mais alors je vais jouer là je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable aussi je vois
ce qui passe aussi sur les réseaux plein
de gens qui disent aussi ouais mais nous
aussi voilà à cause du covid on est bien
sûr on est dans la merde donc comment on
fait si chacun demande un appel aux dons
vous c'est surtout pour les animaux il
faut le rappeler c'est différent c'est
pas pour gagner de l'argent c'est pas là
pour avoir du résultat
il y a personne il y a personne derrière
il y a pas
la chance d'être là tant mieux pour lui
si vous n'obtenez pas cet argent ils
deviennent quoi ces animaux qu'est-ce
qui va se passer Gilles Verdez la région
va vous donner plus d'argent commence
est-ce que vous avez commencé
à votre question on avait démarré une
entreprise tous les deux mon épouse à
deux on l'a entendu on avait 1800
salariés donc pardonnez-moi
je travaillais avec un groupe qui
s'appelait SFR à époque alors on va en
citer d'autres orange
et bien sûr
à cette époque là pour les opérateurs
avaient un peu de mal au début de la
téléphonie cette opérateur me devait
beaucoup d'argent on est parti pour les
12 tous les deux gros sacs qui nous au
contrat à la défense pour les dans le
bureau du PDG on s'est posé devant on a
dormi devant on a attendu que de
repartir avec notre argent et ben je
ferai la même chose ou il faudra aller
pour les animaux quand vous avez
pourquoi il faisons pas donner l'oseille
au départ pardon il faisons pas donner
le les bons ouf
ah ouais mais on s'est battuelle
30 bar
on va aller sauver ces animaux ensemble
je vais t'aider 48 mais on regrette rien
rester 30 après impôts
on a fait le choix de rester en France
et il nous a pas en France et de mettre
l'argent dans une cause qui concerne
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
je vous aime beaucoup
vous sortez de cette cette affaire vous
avez vendu donc 48 millions et vous avez
48 millions il vous en reste 30 là avec
ces 30 millions d'euros vous faites quoi
avec 30000 euros aujourd'hui non l'axe
vous avez fait à l'époque avec ces 30
bûches
[Musique]
en fait vous avez payé
le projet à la base et écoutez écoutez
ça 30 millions
pendant le comide on n'avait pas le
droit au PGE parce qu'on avait pas on
n'avait pas à l'antériorité
on a perdu 7 millions on en avait 3
millions d'emprunt il aurait manqué plus
4 on a remis le reste aujourd'hui une
demande qui est pas beaucoup
pour faire un don les dons qui nous ont
fait aujourd'hui sont dit fiscalisables
à 66 % juste direction donc aujourd'hui
vous vous avez pas d'argent devant vous
vous avez rien
c'est ça non plus grand cramé bien sûr
mais heureux mon épouse
non mais c'est vrai et vous le feriez
savoir quand un animal arrive chez nous
quand un animal a réussi nous sur un
lion un cheval un éléphant n'importe
quoi je sais pas dans quel langage je
sais pas dans quel télépathie je sais
pas dans quel signe on a l'impression
que les autres lui disent t'inquiètes
pas ici on va s'occuper de toi et tu vas
être bien et on a quelques échecs
malheureusement parce qu'on a des bras
cassés mais quand on va un animal qui
bougeait pas qui au bout de deux trois
mois commence à cavaler à courir dans le
truc un tigre qui a passé sa vie tu sais
que moi ici c'est pareil avec eux
[Musique]
je la vois partir je la vois partir en
scooter
la seule différence c'est que chez nous
tous les animaux qui arrivent chez nous
parce qu'on part du principe c'est pas
la peine de faire des animaux sauvages
en captivité pour leur captivité et son
casque tout ce qui arrive chez nous et
cassé
on les déteste
mais Patrick j'ai une question un peu
intime et vous n'êtes pas obligé de me
répondre est-ce que vous avez des
enfants j'ai un fils et deux petits fils
donc ils sont parfaitement en face avec
ça
quand on a un peu d'argent et qu'on
dépense son argent dans une cause on
doit on doit en parler à ses enfants à
son fils non mais bien sûr
[Rires]
il est quand même louable parce que
c'est vrai que il y a pas beaucoup de
gens
30 millions d'euros net impôts et se
dire je vais les réinvestir pour sauver
des animaux les gars c'est quand même
vraiment aimé les animaux
professionnel on s'est occupé beaucoup
d'humains on s'occuper énormément de
jeunes en difficulté avec des substances
etc et vous savez que vous avez 1800
salariés vous en avez 15 de plus en
difficulté ça se voit pas comme une
entreprise qui tourne la téléphonie
tourner donc je m'occuper du mal et
croyez-moi s'occuper d'une jeune
toxicoman c'est plus de boulot de
s'occuper d'une tigresse moi j'en ai une
ici
pas évident c'est la tigresse de la
tigresse de Casablanca
tu connais le fantasme de la Fontaine
non non c'est d'avoir un manteau en peau
de
[Rires]
tu dégages tu sors tu dégages bon
écoutez on se tient au courant Patrick
hein on va voir comment ça va évolué
pour vous ça va bien se passer bon vous
avez confiance je suis confiant d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a une calculette vous comprenez pas
en fait
c'est parce que je pense que vous avez
je vous jure que c'est vrai je pense que
vraiment c'est le cœur qui a parlé bravo
à vous